[Music]
from the moment she strolled into my
office i could tell she was gonna be a
difficult sentence to read
you could tell from the way she walked
that she was carrying a lot of
information but getting it out of her
wouldn't be easy i was gonna need
to make an
inference hey what's up readers david
here i'm taking advantage of the cold
that i have by doing my serious
detective voice in order to teach you
about inferences
hold on let me get that
hi uh this is david i'm in the middle of
doing a video now now isn't a great time
oh oh that's great uh
cool follow me over to the next screen
what is an inference please
great
thank you
was that all you needed yeah that was my
whole thing all right thanks bye
so an inference is a conclusion that you
draw from writing it's an idea that you
pull from a sentence or a passage that
isn't literally printed there it's the
detective work of reading finding clues
that help you make sense of what's being
said i feel like we're kind of getting
bogged down in theory land so let's take
a look at an example i went outside and
made an enormous snow fort
there's my snow fort a little d on the
flag to represent me
there's my little hot cocoa couple
marshmallows floating in there my khan
academy mug they don't make khan academy
mugs i want a khan academy mug
okay so what conclusions can we draw
from these two sentences i went outside
and made an enormous snow fort beautiful
brilliant enormous then i came inside
and had a big mug of hot chocolate same
deal beautiful brilliant enormous what
conclusions can i draw about this
situation well if you're making things
out of snow and then you're coming
inside and having hot chocolate it's
probably not the height of summer one
inference that i can draw from these two
sentences together is that it is winter
time when this sentence takes place
where i live these are not activities
that one pursues in the height of summer
outside so i'm looking for clues within
the text snow fort i'm outside i came
inside and then i had hot chocolate
which is not traditionally a beverage
that is consumed when it's warm out
let's take a look at another example
this paragraph is part of a longer
passage that is about a young ballet
dancer named michaela michaela danced so
wonderfully that she was awarded a
scholarship to attend the jacqueline
kennedy o'nasa school at the american
ballet theater that was only the
beginning of her dancing success
when she was 17 michaela danced with the
dance theater of harlem professional
company
later she joined the dutch national
junior company today michaela is a
soloist with the dutch national ballet
so very quickly without getting bogged
down in this passage what are some
conclusions what are some inferences
that we can draw about michaela who is
michaela
what do we know about her we know that
she's a dancer
we know that she's very good at it right
she danced so wonderfully that she got a
scholarship so i'm going to say michaela
is very talented
and we know that her talent led to
success because her getting the
scholarship was only the beginning of
her dancing success
we can see from the passage that she was
part of at least three different dance
companies the dance theater of harlem
the dutch national junior company and as
a solos with the dutch national ballet
today so i'm going to say that michaela
is a very hard worker
now notice nowhere in the passage does
it say
michaela is a very talented hard-working
dancer just like in the previous example
it didn't say it was winter outside so i
made a snow for it what the skill of
inference is
requires you to be a detective and take
your magnifying glass
to the passage to discover clues imagine
you're a detective like this dog
who's wearing a little deer stalker cap
let's call them
let's call him sherlock bones the famous
dog detective that i just made up
and i feel like sherlock holmes is
always smoking a pipe so i'm going to
give this dog like a
i don't know a bone or a piece of
rawhide or something
so imagine that you are a detective or a
dog detective if you like and every time
you read a text let's say a book that
you are searching for clues
within it what you're doing when you
make an inference is you are taking the
information that you already know about
the world and the places and people in
it and how they behave and what they
look like and what they do and you're
applying that knowledge to the text when
do people build snowmen when do people
build snow forts when do they drink hot
cocoa in the winter time
an important thing to remember though is
that inferring is not guessing any time
you make an inference you have to be
pulling it directly from the text that's
your jumping off point it can't just be
a wild gas out of nowhere it comes from
information that you've got there on the
page
now if you'll excuse me i'm going to go
eat my weight in cough drops
you can learn anything dave it out